- [Narrator] Evergrande is the world's
most indebted real estate firm,
and it's been flooding
its social media accounts
with videos like this,
showing that the company is back to work.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Meanwhile, buyers
and real estate vloggers
are also taking to social media
to complain about construction delays
or that they haven't
received their new homes.
The Wall Street Journal
examined these posts
to understand why people are upset,
even as Evergrande has been
trying to fulfill pledges
it has made to regulators to deliver more
than one million pre-sold homes.
If the company can't
meet it's obligations,
consumer confidence could tank,
rippling through the Chinese economy
and potentially impacting
the global economy.
- It has definitely turned
from being that
prestigious developer giant
into something that
everyone's concerned about.
- [Narrator] So we
compared social media posts
from people waiting for homes
they've already paid for.
And ones from Evergrande as it promises
to do whatever it takes to deliver them.
But first, here's how one
of China's largest property
developers ended up
with so many stalled construction sites.
Pandemic lockdowns had
hurt the company's sales
and new government rules kept it
from borrowing more money.
Then this past summer,
Evergrande said it was
experiencing a cash crunch
and construction at
many of its 778 projects
in 233 cities were halted.
All across China, the company has offices
and many have their own social
media accounts on WeChat,
one of the country's most
popular messaging apps.
We looked at content
published by 20 of them
between September and November.
Most of the posts follow
a similar pattern.
First, the company says it's working hard
to deliver homes and resume construction.
Then there are either videos or photos
of workers returning
to empty project sites.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] And testimonials from buyers
who've signed contracts to
move into their new homes.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] These homeowners
are among the many urban Chinese
who plowed their savings into new homes.
Collectively, they have nearly
78% of their wealth tied up
in residential property.
- The property market in China
is very important to its economy.
Real estate activity accounts
for roughly 1/4 of China's
GDP and a central concern
for the government is making sure
that people get the
properties that they paid for.
- [Narrator] Economists
and real estate agents
in China say there's a lot at stake.
Evergrande has an estimated
1.4 million pre-sold
apartments outstanding.
And if they aren't finished,
many households could
suffer painful losses,
shaking confidence in the
country's property market.
And a downturn in the world's
second-largest economy
could spread to other countries trying
to bounce back from the pandemic.
- So Evergrande has to make
this their priority as well,
and the best way to deliver the flats
is to find ways to resume construction.
- [Narrator] Local authorities
are also helping out the company.
Most of the cities with
Evergrande projects
have set up task forces
to help manage the process
and hired accountants to
comb through their finances.
In early November,
Evergrande said it had handed
over more than 57,000 homes
between July and October.
- These announcements
can give a bit of hope
to buyers who are in a desperate situation
of having poured so much money
into these unfinished
apartments they've bought.
And this is probably just the beginning
of this colossal process
to restart constructions
at these unfinished sites,
and many, many more are still
waiting for their homes.
- [Narrator] And some of those waiting
have been using various
social media platforms
to vent their frustration.
We looked at 20 posts from buyers
who said that construction
appeared stalled
or doubted they would move into
their new homes on schedule.
- I do want to point out
that some buyers have expressed
relief on social media
about finally getting their homes
and that others also have
complained about water
and gas leaks, or even
unfinished interiors.
And people have seen
empty construction sites,
so how the company is gonna turn around
will be scrutinized by people
because this involves
something as intimate
and as important to them as their homes.
- [Narrator] Evergrande
has promised home buyers
to deliver what they have paid for
but there are also unfinished buildings
with apartments that haven't been sold
and a lower priority for the company.
We looked at posts from
real estate vloggers
who review property sites
and provide investment tips,
and they've been doing
their own inspections
of Evergrande projects.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] This footage was filmed
by real estate vlogger He Peiqi.
She went to this site
called Evergrande City
in Hhhot, Inner Mongolia in November.
A month earlier, the company posted photos
of Evergrande City,
and said more than 1,400
apartments across six buildings
have been finished.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] This footage shows
that about a month
after that announcement,
Evergrande City had
other buildings waiting
to resume construction.
Evergrande says it's
working with the government
and in early December, the
government of Guangdong,
the province where the company is based,
said it will send a working group
to help the developer
work out its problems
and maintain normal operations.
Evergrande has around $20 billion worth
of outstanding dollar bonds
and it's managed to
avoid defaulting on them
by making last-minute
interest payments on deadline.
For this video, the company declined
to respond to requests for comment
on specific instances
of delayed construction,
the poor quality of some finished homes
and whether the company was aware
of complaints on social media.
So until the home owners get the keys
to the apartments they bought,
they have social media to share
their concerns with others
and check on the progress of their homes.
(pensive music)